[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
Rhett
that's right
you just got me this week
uh you have one of the lifelong friends
because the other lifelong friend is
living it up
he's living it up on the slopes
hopefully staying intact
um I haven't gotten any texts or any
calls yet from him or anybody in this
family
informing me that he has broken his
other collarbone so fingers crossed I'm
recording this on a Thursday of the week
that he is gone and he will be
having his last day on the slopes
tomorrow so so far so good
but yeah we were like let's do I don't
think we've ever done this before Jenna
do you remember us ever doing this I do
not I don't remember this ever happening
um there's been a couple of times in the
history of
Good Mythical Morning in which one of us
has been gone where somebody has subbed
in
um but we were thinking like uh what are
we gonna do and uh I don't know what I
don't know exactly what links got
planned uh for when I'm gonna be out of
town
I don't know how he's gonna handle it
but I was like you know what I'll do a
solo one and Jen is here on my on the
mic so you know I'm comfortable doing
things by myself but I'm so used to
having someone here link is his name and
he sits right here
and when you have somebody that you're
doing a podcast with there are these
moments that when they're talking you
can kind of be like okay I'm not talking
right now I can think about what I'm
going to say I can take a sip of
whatever I'm drinking
where are you supposed to look now
I'm kind of just looking at my camera
here but to make it easier
um instead of just doing listen what
Emma Chamberlain does is kind of
remarkable when you think about it
because she just
sits there and talks and remains very
interesting
uh and I don't listen to her podcast on
a regular basis so I'm not sure if she
answers questions but the few episodes
that I've listened to it seems like
she's just kind of just talking the
whole time I'm gonna take the easy way
out and I'm going to make this a
conversation with you because
we told you that I was going to be doing
this episode and we asked you to ask me
some questions
but I do want to give you a little
update
this is the kind of thing that I would
share with link if he was here uh and
that is I had a little bit of a full
circle moment this week you might know
if you've
been around for a while that we are a
little bit Infamous for a stunt that we
pulled
after college
in which as I have maintained for many
years I did not actually participate
directly in this meaning I did not take
a dookie in the Tupperware that was
placed into the chip bag and then taken
to a party
and put under a couch and subsequently
ruined a party it was very immature
we had to apologize directly uh to the
women whose house this was and we saw it
as a good-natured prank but it was not
good natured it was foul and uh I don't
know why we continue to talk about it
but the reason I'm talking about it
today is because this week I did
something that in any other context
would be considered a prank and that is
I put my [__] in a box and mailed it
[Laughter]
I'm 45.
and that is when you're supposed to
start putting your [__] in a box and
mailing it to a lab
uh so I do plan on getting I'll explain
why I did this uh I do plan on getting a
colonoscopy
and maybe link and I will go get
colonoscopies together I mean we got
vasectomies together so that is
something that is there's a discussion
that is ongoing about that
but because link turns 45 a little bit
after me I wanted to get the head start
on him
and you know you can there's a service
where you can [__] in a box uh it's more
than just [__] in a box just so you
understand
there's multiple layers involved it's
like any box uh you know it's a specific
box there is a specific receptacle
there is I mean there is kind of a
process I'm not going to go into the
things that you have to do but it seems
that the part that was the most uh
potentially humiliating to me
first of all I had to tell Jesse because
uh I I there's a thing that you put over
the toilet to catch your [__] right so
you don't have to like just [__] in your
hand and put in a box they don't make
you do that thank God they've really
thought about this maybe the first
person that shipped their [__] [__] in
their hand
but since then they have perfected this
and it's just a little plastic thing
that you put on the toilet and you just
feel like you're just taking a regular
[__]
but I did tell my wife I was like don't
go in the bathroom for a while because
I'm working one up and uh I've already
placed the contraction in the toilet and
I just don't want you to even see this
contraption I don't I only want you to
see the box when it's fully sealed
because I want to you know maintain the
romance
and we have a strong relationship long
relationship and we are not one of those
couples that don't fart around each
other and
you know somebody's defecating maybe the
door is cracked open I don't know we
don't like you know we're not sitting in
each other's laps taking shits or
anything like that nothing against you
if you do that kind of thing
um but that's not how we do it but we're
not embarrassed about those things
bodily functions is a natural part of
being a person
uh but I didn't want her to to see this
so uh yeah there is a process but you
you've you seal it up and then you put
there's a bag inside the box that a
sealed container goes into you pour some
kind of like preservative onto it
and then you just peel off the label and
it goes to the lab but you do have to
take it into the UPS
store right
and the Box
has
like branding on it for this company
and it says
human specimen or something like that on
it
and I and you know that the person
working at the UPS store has collected
enough of these ship boxes to know when
a [__] box is coming in
and I could tell by the way the woman
looked at me
yep you're of age I know that there's
[__] in this box you are [__]
and to hand somebody
your [__] in a box
and it's not a prank it's just like yep
I know where this is going in fact she
said would you like a receipt
I almost said no not a shame but I said
yes because I figured maybe
I needed some proof that I sent my [__]
off and so we'll see what happens
um
I read a little bit about the service
and apparently there's a relatively High
false positive
uh that comes from this so you could be
told that you might have colon cancer
and you don't like 13 of the time so
there's like a one in ten chance that
I get a false positive and then
there is a chance that it detects
something and I need to get a
colonoscopy earlier than I thought but
anyway just a little personal update for
me
I I we I have a couple of uh things
we're going to do I've got your
voicemail questions that some of you
asked and I've got some Twitter
questions that some of you asked and
I'll just be bouncing back and forth
between the two let's start with a
voicemail
hi Rhett this is Gage I'm from Michigan
been a long time fan my question for you
is did you ever get made fun of in
school for being so tall
thank you man have a good day
thank you Gage you have a good day too
um have I ever been bullied for being
tall you know I actually
and I probably have told this story
before I I was bullied
a little bit in school and it was mostly
because of the fact that
because I played basketball and I was on
the varsity team even as a freshman like
I got pulled up for the playoffs as a
freshman because I was tall and my
brother was on the basketball team I
wasn't that good yet
but because I was this young guy on the
varsity and then the next year uh as a
sophomore on the varsity team
I was a little bit of a Target right
and when the bullying would start
it would be about how skinny skinny I
was or how tall I was so that that and
that was part of it there was one guy
I won't say his name but he that it was
I was the most like intense bullying
um that I that I've experienced of like
being cornered in a locker room and like
kind of being like punched around like
not in the face or anything but like
punched in the shoulder and stuff at the
time
it was just like oh this is what this
guy does to everybody and I'm gonna kind
of laugh it off and just kind of get out
of it
but I didn't even this is the weird
thing about how different it was
in the 90s I never thought about that as
bullying until
I had kids in school and everyone talks
about bullying and a lot more like
um uh aware
and informed way but yeah I guess I was
bullied and it would turn into mostly
how skinny I was which I think was a
function of how tall I was
so maybe not directly because of how
tall I was but I was only on the
basketball team because of how tall I
was initially
so I could link my bullying to my
tallness in that way
thanks for the question Gage
this one is from this is from Twitter
this is uh novocaine96 who retweeted a
tweet that I tweeted in 2019
and you know what I figured this is as
good a time as any to finally
give you some direction here because I
talked for many many years about telling
y'all my back routine my like back
stretching core exercise routine I talk
about how I do it every single day
without fail which is true I like never
miss it
definitely haven't missed a day in 2023
and probably missed like one day in 2022
because of some weird circumstance
but uh novocaine said
Rhett is soon gonna happen asking for me
or asking for a me because I said in 19
uh
we'll share soon
well I'm a little late and I'm actually
not going to share my routine because
I'm gonna just I'm gonna point you to a
resource okay
and that's the reason I'm not going to
share my routine is because my routine
is ever evolving
it's constantly incorporating new things
based on need and based on
I'm being served up all these uh
Instagram videos and Tick Tock videos
about Mobility again something about my
age Mobility stretching knee stuff back
stuff and it's like I'm meeting that
stuff up like you would not believe like
they totally know their target audience
I want all of it anything to do with
needs anything to do with back I'm going
to sit there for hours watching it
making my back and knee problems worse
by the way just sitting there in bad
posture watching this stuff
uh but I'm what I'm going to do is I'm
going to share with you or point you to
a video that I think covers the core of
what I do and what has remained the core
of what I do every single morning now if
you have any sort of lower back issues
any sort of mobility issues
it basically every single day that I get
up
without fail
when I get out of the bed my back is
tight
and it hurts a little bit to move now
there were years probably 10 years ago
in which it was awful and it like I
would wake up in like a six or seven out
of ten in pain in the morning and just
kind of thought it was normal
now it's more like two or three on the
scale
uh but what I'm gonna point you to if
you just go to YouTube and you search
six of the best lower back exercises
your new back Mobility routine this is
from a channel called prehab I'm not
endorsing this channel I mean I am
because I'm pointing into a video but in
a very quick sort of search this guy
seemed legitimate and he was doing uh
the things that I do like the core of
what I do
and he seemed like he was informed the
most important piece of the routine for
me and the thing that I'll do like if
I'm in a weird scenario where
I don't know I wake up in like a
on a boat
which actually has never happened
but let's just assume that if I were to
wake up on a boat and I didn't have like
the space that I typically have what's
the one thing that I would do is the cat
and cow you know you get on your hands
and knees and you arch your back some
people call it the camel I don't know
cat and cow you know what I'm talking
about Jenna yes yeah I only know it as
cat and cow so
this is basically getting on all fours
your knees and your hands and then
arching your back each way slowly and
like boy that is just and you can really
kind of just get it where you can move
your butt around and kind of move in
different positions and like that is
such a non-negotiable for me
and the one exercise because this is all
about mobility in this video but the one
exercise that I do that I would say is
also indispensable
people call it different things
but it's kind of the like you look like
a dog pointing you know you're on all
fours and you lift up your right arm and
your left leg
and you switch and lift up your left arm
and your right leg and you keep your
core really like tight
because you're not actually trying to
use your lower back muscles to do it to
to engage you're engaging your entire
core some people just call it like an
arm and leg raise whatever
I think you know what I'm talking about
I just call it the pointer thing because
it's like a dog
I do that every single day too because
it just kind of like from for it it gets
the blood flowing to the right places
so I don't know how satisfying that was
because I did say that I was going to
make a video
and I decided not to make a video I
decided to point you to other videos and
then point you to an exercise that I
cannot remember the name of so maybe
that wasn't satisfying
bouncing table pose balancing table pose
that's what they call it
I'll take it
let's move on to another voicemail
hi Rhett it is I Brett my question for
you is if you are offered immortality by
an omnipone being today would you take
it why or why not and if so what would
you do with your Immortal Life and let's
assume that is the regenerative kind so
any pre-existing physical ailments or if
you lost a finger it would all be healed
up in short time thanks my partner and I
are big fans bye-bye
Brett
Rhett
in brit
I always use your name Brett
as a way of explaining what my name is
my go-to is Brett without the B if I'm
in a loud environment what's your name
Rhett Rick like Brett without the B
[Laughter]
it tends to work
I've almost considered just changing my
name to Brett because people probably
don't maybe people think he said bread
Brett Brad Brett like Rhett with a B oh
you're doing that's what you're doing
isn't it hmm
immortality
first of all I may be immortal
I don't know
meaning
this version of my Consciousness may go
on and exist after it has manifested in
this body I don't know right
now there's a lot of people out there
who believe it definitely will and that
my particular Consciousness will be
going to hell
um I'm almost certain that's not true
um
I'm almost one of the things I think
I've said this before I I think I've
said that before I say that a lot I
think I've said that before something I
said before and I'm sorry I say that so
much but we talk a lot on the internet
but I think that any conception that any
particular person on Earth or any system
of thought including religions
uh any conception that they have of the
afterlife any specific conception is
almost certainly not true
like one of the ways that you can figure
out what doesn't happen after you die is
if some existing religion on Earth
says that that's what happens that's my
that's my view of it right that's how
you rule things out when somebody says
this is what happens when you die
well that's almost assuredly what
doesn't happen when you die just
mathematically speaking
but I believe you I don't know what
happens when I die so
if I was betting on it
I would bet that this particular
arrangement of my consciousness
goes away right sure my atoms and maybe
some form of spirit that I don't
understand uh goes on and has some sort
of existence
but because I think that most likely
like this version of me in this
Consciousness is finite the idea of
immortality is very attractive so
attractive in fact that I think it's
probably the reason that many of us
believe in religion
um
and why religion is so attractive and
it's so attractive to me
but because it's it's such an attractive
concept and I and I re I actually I
really enjoy life I I enjoy new
experiences and learning new things that
I think I have found a way to have my
cake and eat it too Brett
I think
I would say yes
to immortality
and now the first thing you think when
you hear that is
surely you're gonna get tired of
existing and there's going to be a time
in which you just want to pull the plug
in it if you are truly Immortal you
can't do that right
but what I think you can do is I think
you can induce coma
okay
so I know you said that this was the
regenerative kind of immortality and I
don't know if that means you're coma
resistant
but you're still in a regular body it's
just Immortal right so I think you could
do the whole Disney thing like the Walt
Disney thing
which I don't actually think that he did
that but just did he do that did he
freeze his head did he do that or is
that just a rumor uh I uh I think that's
just a room okay well people do that I
need to look it up you can cry oh freeze
yourself right
and so I think what I would do is I
would have
um
first thing I would do is I would just
do like induced Comas for like long naps
just call them long naps and I would
wake back up and I would like reinvent
myself and then when I got tired of that
existence I would induce another coma
um now first of all yes to answer the
obvious question I would fully fulfill
my duties and finish my my life with
with Jesse and my kids and then at some
point you know my kids are going to have
kids maybe
they're gonna like at some point like
yeah okay I'm a great grandfather one of
these days I'll be like great great
granddaddy red
is about to take a long nap and when he
wakes up he's not gonna have anything to
do with y'all because he's you know what
I'm saying like because at this point
we're just so distantly related you know
I'm traveling all the time I'm spending
a lot of time on the other side of the
world whatever
I will have maintained my distance from
my descendants right because at some
point I have to detach then I would
induce the coma
for a certain amount of time I'd have to
have a really good relationship with a
doctor
who would somehow pass on their
knowledge of my situation because I mean
worst case scenario I guess it's not
even that worst case scenario it's I
just remain in a coma forever and then
it's just like I died right
so I think that's my answer I would take
immortality with intermittent Comas
or freezing
uh Fluttershy
how is your James and the shame project
going updates on the final or any future
songs or possibilities
this is the question that I chose from
there was a sort of a vein of questions
about James and the shame so I thought I
would give my full James in the shame
update now while link isn't here and he
doesn't have to just sit there and
listen to me talk about my solo project
I'll just do it now while I'm soloing
this podcast
um
the update on James and the shame uh you
know people ask are you gonna tour
you're gonna play like probably not you
know I I uh I'm very very focused like
my PR my my priorities in terms of my
creative Focus right now have always
been and are especially right now what
we're doing at mythical right so
uh what what I'm doing right now your
biscuits Good Mythical Morning
those are things that are going to keep
happening for an indefinite amount of
time
and I have never been more excited about
what we're doing creatively on the Rhett
and Link channel
and uh we have so many ideas that we
want to get out there and so that's
where my sort of creative passion is
right now however I can't stop writing
music I've probably written another 10
songs since the album came out right
and I have made you know I slowly dip
into that and and
um continue to to record demos I'm
trying to figure out what I'm going to
do the good news is is that a lot of the
groundwork that I laid
to kind of get everything set up you
know all the accounts at all the places
and the website and Etc
that's all in place and that took a lot
of my time
in the initial sort of run now if I had
a song and it was produced I could just
distribute it and it would show up and
it would go to all the right places so
the the lift involved in getting new
music out there is a lot lower so I have
plans to release more stuff I just don't
know when that's going to happen there's
no timeline on that at all
I'm just kind of keeping it active right
specifically with the uh human overboard
stuff where the sort of James and the
shame
first album
the update is when you're listening to
this uh uh you will likely
either be getting your vinyl any day now
because I have actually I haven't
received them when I'm recording this
but they came a little bit earlier than
we expected which we were hoping
and so how that translates into when
they ship out
I'm not exactly sure but
they're printed they're ready to go
they're being packed up and shipped soon
so you might have them by the time you
listen to this
uh and also
I probably will have already announced
that I got a little a secondary little
merch run that I did that I'm doing for
the spring
when I did uh the merch associated with
human overboard you know in addition to
the selling the physical album just to
be honest with you like we did some very
simple designs and like threw some
things together I was happy with it but
it wasn't like super high design High
concept and like super creative stuff
it was like you know tasteful getting a
logo onto a shirt kind of thing
but I've always wanted to do something
that was more design conscious and more
thoughtful
and so if it's not out now it'll be out
very very soon
at jamesonthesham.com is the Leviathan
collection right so a lot of people ask
about
the album cover right and there's these
like octopus tentacles coming up and
grabbing me and then there's a boat in
the back and both of those things are
sort of biblical imagery right that's
Noah's Ark in the back which kind of
represents the ship of belief as I've
used in that analogy and then that
creature is not an octopus not a giant
squiz the Leviathan
which is you know this is from mythology
as well not just the Bible but basically
you know some symbolic of Chaos
and
uh because again that's sort of the
perception that I have always had about
people who leave who left the faith and
I know that's the perception that a lot
of people have about me from leaving the
faith is that I'm jumping into chaos
right and I'm being wrapped up by the
world
so I love that imagery in a dark kind of
sense
and uh we put together a few designs
that if you're watching the video right
now I'm showing you those
we've got this design which is the
Leviathan kind of taking over my head
Leviathan taking over a guitar
and then we have the a new James and the
shame sort of text logo that is the
Leviathan uh tentacles making the text
and that's going to be released as a
t-shirt a couple T-shirts a hoodie a
sticker pack and a bandana
it's country music so you got to have a
bandana anyway I'm like very very happy
uh with this with this collection I
think it kind of represents what I
wanted to do with merch and what I plan
to do with any kind of merch that I do
that's kind of got more of like a high
design High concept approach to it
so anyway that's the update on James and
the shame I don't I have no uh I was so
it was so fun to play live at mythicon
but there's just the the amount of uh
coordination that would have to take
place in order to play live like
especially with a band is just not
something that's in the cards right now
and so I just don't I can't prioritize
it and I'm just more interested in
getting the music out there
uh and people being able to experience
it in that way and also just quickly
last thing I'll say
little to none of the music that I'm
writing right now is a deconstruction
themed just so you know I kind of felt
like that was like that was the first
album and just I don't know there's just
it's all kinds of subject matter at this
point
um
and and uh
style wise kind of the same but changing
a little bit but anyway I'm having a
good time doing it hopefully you'll hear
it at some point
quick uh announcement speaking of vinyls
you can get uh this right here the my
hair goes vinyl
this is the latest quarterly collectible
item on the mythical Society so
um
for years for years people have been
asking us to rewrite the song now that
my hair goes down and links here it goes
up and so we do
we completely re-recorded the song uh
Mark Byers our producer completely redid
I mean it's basically
an updated version of the song itself uh
of the the original song so it kind of
sounds true to the original but much
better
you can see we've basically this is
homage to the artwork that was in the
song uh
and there it is and then the record
itself
is this nice blue
I like that I like that those colored
vinyls uh you can get this oh and also
it not only does it have the original
version of my hair it goes it has a 2023
updated version with the reverse and on
side B it's got
Our Song relevant
which
did we ever play that anywhere
I I we wrote it for something and we
played it oh we played it at we played
it on the tool on the um rent and Link
tour the song yep we did uh was that the
relevant one it was VidCon London
VidCon London we like special
performance of that song
and I guess maybe we performed it
somewhere else anyway it's a completely
original Rhett and Link song that we
wrote a while back
uh that has never been
distributed and it has it was never put
on Spotify or anything
I don't think so anyway you can get this
mythical society.com it's third degree
join third degree monthly or third
degree uh yeah monthly by April 30th
third degree monthly by April 30th if
you want to get that vinyl
earbiscus is brought to you by
betterhelp therapy is all about
deepening yourself especially on
self-awareness and understanding getting
to the root of why you are the way you
are we're big fans of therapy and
accessible therapy at that and that's
where better help comes in to connect
you with a licensed therapist to take
you on your journey of self-discovery
we've been on journeys of self-discovery
um through therapy over the past few
years also on this podcast uh yeah yeah
and that is exhibited through the
podcast
but it has become a indispensable part
of our growth yeah so we want you to try
out therapy and better help is a great
way to do that completely online and
affordable just fill out a questionnaire
to get matched to a licensed therapist
and change at any time with no extra
cost to you discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com ear
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
here's another Twitter question from
Brittany
okay hypothetical question
in a mass zombie slash shutdown
situation
do you stay put for a period of time or
head Inland with hope of making it past
the mountains for safety Brittany
I cannot tell you how many times I've
thought about this
not specifically about a zombie
situation I don't
actually think that that's plausible
but there are many uh [__] hitting the
fan types of situations that could
happen
I mean we kind of live in a constant
[__] hitting the fan situation right now
and so it's like there's nothing that
could surprise me at this point
um
many different things could go wrong
right
and
Los Angeles is like one of the worst
places you could be right just like one
of the worst places you could be
and I think about this on a pretty
regular basis because
you know how I think about the
apocalypse into the world stuff
and I'd like to think that I'm prepared
I'm not really I have some stuff I've
got some food
you know
but not enough I mean we already know
that Link's gonna be at my house with
this whole family they're gonna be my
stuff I mean I gave him when I got ready
with my stuff a while back I gave him
some stuff but you know he's gonna run
out he's gonna show up at my place all
of a sudden all the McLaughlin's anneals
are all together
and um
and then whoever else you know and so
la
if you go
South
you basically I mean you can you get to
eventually get to San Diego eventually
get to Mexico
um
that's that's actually probably the only
direction that you could you could head
if you were trying to get out of town
right because if you go east
you can eventually hit desert right if
you go north you're going to very
quickly come to just it's so desolate
it's so desolate like we just drove up
there the other day uh for a video and
as soon as you leave Los Angeles you're
in this desolate mountain range and then
you come down to the hill on your way to
Bakersfield and it's just I mean there's
nothing out there right
being on the East Coast would be such a
better situation
and you know of course we have a family
we have family on the East Coast if we
could get to the if I knew something was
about to hit a fan like if I had a real
indication that things were about to go
sideways I would get to the East Coast
as fast as I could because there's like
more regular water sources you know
less people
Etc but I think honestly like if there
was a giant earthquake that shut things
down
I think I'd just behold and steady for
as long as I could I definitely don't
think I'd start there's just no good
place to go around here right
and you're gonna be going there with
millions of people who are also trying
to get on the roads everything's going
to be completely uh backed up
so I think I would just take my chances
at home
but I do think about it
and I do have some I do know some of
some spots in the mountains that I have
like scoped out that like there's like
little streams and stuff
but I just know I'm gonna have to like
fight people over it
I think about this when I'm hiking
I'm crazy
I'm hiking and I like see a little creek
and there's not there's not a lot of
streams and stuff like actively in the
mountains right now they're all filled
with water because it's been raining but
they dry up quite a bit
but I'm like yeah I could I could set up
a little shelter there and then people
would be coming in here to try to get
water and I'd have to like judge whether
or not I was going to let them in and
then like we have to have some sort of
system and how long would this water
last I think about these things what am
I going to do to filter it
how many deer are there really in this
Woods that we could eat
when we can start eating each other
thanks for the pick me up Brittany
okay
let's have another voicemail
yeah I just want to know like what's
Red's hair routine
okay
um
okay I get asked this question a lot and
again I'm going to take the opportunity
of a link not being present because you
can you imagine
can you imagine what link would do to me
if I went into my hair routine to get
you to imagine how hard of it you you
people think that I give him a hard time
have you ever actually listened to the
way we interact have you actually ever
listened to the things he says to me
have you actually ever processed it
he wouldn't let me get away with that
for a minute without making fun of me
every witch away
just saying
so I'm going to take advantage of this
opportunity where he's not present to
tell you my hair routine
listen
it's not exciting there's not a lot
that's gonna uh there's not a lot to it
and
all I do
is literally
about once a week I wash my hair
okay let me just start there
I wash it
and condition it and like
brush it out
like once a week and if it's a week
where I'm like working out a lot or
getting really sweaty I'll add a second
wash in there but I don't wash it very
often that's the first thing I do
the second thing I do and it doesn't
stink if that's what you're asking my
hair doesn't stink okay
partly because
the only product I put into it is this
um curl renew spray I've used a couple
of different brands I'm not going to
endorse anyone there's many out there
and they all kind of work the same as
far as I can tell
I basically take a shower
and I take a shower at night wash my
hair go to uh bed with my hair kind of
wet and then I wake up the next day and
I spray this curl renew stuff in there
and then that's like the only thing that
I put into my hair besides spraying
water on it to get it to reactivate that
stuff and that's all I do
and it only that works on my hair and
people have been like I'm trying to grow
my hair out and I'm like listen if you
don't have
a little it's like slightly curly hair
that probably won't work for you either
have like Jenny you've got curlier hair
than me
you probably have to do you do something
else I assume uh yeah I yeah yeah I do
different stuff than you but the the
spritzing with water
um that's all curly hair that works for
that you do right that was a big tip um
hooked us up with that tip
um and if your hair is straight
with no curling at all I mean it's like
you can't I don't think you can make it
curly without like some sort of
lots of product Contraption or something
lots of product and probably
um like a curling iron yeah because
people are like do the curly girl method
or whatever I'm like listen I don't
I don't like having my hair long I don't
like the inconvenience that's why that
listen that's why I watched it once I
didn't I'm not like I watch it once a
week because you shouldn't wash your
hair more than once a week I wash it
once a week because it takes too damn
long to wash it and condition and comb
it all out and so I'm just like yeah
that once a week it gets pretty naughty
I'm in the shower for a while
it's probably not advisable I should
probably watch it more I don't know I'm
just telling you what I do that's what
you asked
I'm not recommending it but yeah I'm
just saying put some of that curl renew
stuff in there I've used the cheap ones
and the expensive ones they all seem to
work about the same and then spray a
little bit of water on your hair like if
I'm coming in and we're going to shoot
GMM and I've got
that stuff in my hair I'll just spray a
little water and it's like okay it's
kind of curly sometimes it looks better
than others sometimes it does get a
little greasy looking
like right now
I'm on day four
okay
that's what it looks like day four
we need to get you some dry shampoo well
I've done the dry shampoo
you don't like it I did it for a while
but it kind of like
I don't know I feel like it gives me
dandruff it like dries my scalp out I
make my own I don't use this you make
your own dry shampoo yeah because that
also sprays usually for dark hair just
it doesn't work it doesn't it it's
always like a grayish tint that it
leaves I can see that
here's a Twitter question for
t1d Chuck
why are you still doing what you do
this is not a jab I love your work but
curious
about what motivates you to keep going
and moving forward
this is representative of a question
that seemed to come from a number of
people like what keeps you motivated
what gets you up in the morning why do
you keep going you've been doing this
for a long time
um
I think it first of all let me just
start by saying I think it's at least
partly pathological
um
I don't think I have a diagnosable uh
disorder
but I do have a personality that is
um
just I don't know I
every day I wake up I'm kind of
overwhelmed with a number of things that
I want to do and I'm sort of preoccupied
with a number of things that I haven't
yet to do that I want to do
professionally
the ideas that I want to bring into the
world and the things that I want to try
and so far fingers crossed those ideas
have never stopped coming right the the
ideas continue to kind of overwhelm me
I'm not and I'm probably going to go
through I'm sure I'll go through some
sort of creative drought people ask
about that a lot and the reason I don't
answer that question I'm like well it
hasn't happened yet thankfully
usually it's creative overload it's too
many things at once
too many things that I'm really
passionate about and too many things
that I want to try and then I'll just
start doing them
and I think I kind of live my life in
the deep end meaning I'm Treading Water
I'm constantly treading water and when I
wake up it and this is going to sound
this might sound like kind of torturous
and I'll get to the good part of this in
a second but like when I wake up it
feels like I'm waking up in the deep end
and I gotta I can't go back to sleep
when I wake up
because 17 things enter my mind that I
could be working on that I need to be
moving forward and I've been this way
for a really long time
and so I say pathological because I
don't think that that's necessarily
normal and I don't think that's healthy
um I've actually been
doing a better job of recording my
dreams lately
to kind of I've been doing this because
some so many of you uh suggested that I
read more about
uh Carl Jung
uh
I think I'm just going to say Carl Young
because every time I try to say the way
you actually pronounce his name my wife
laughs at me because it's just one of
those things that I can't quite get
right like I listened to a book and
people say Jung then people say Young
and then people say Young
and I can already pronounce the word
young so I'm going to just say that
Carl Young
he was really into dreams
and I was just like out of curiosity I
you know I'm just going to start
recording more more of my dreams I'd
like to get better at that
have some crazy dreams but
what I've noticed is that so many of my
dreams are me facing a really like
insurmountable problem
like I'll be in a weird situation
and I'll be like I'm trying to get out
of this Canyon and then I get to the
edge and there's a weird incline and I
know that I'm not gonna it's like how am
I gonna grip that and then kind of in
the middle of addressing that challenge
I'll wake up last night I had a dream
that I had been drafted to the NBA to
play for the Lakers which
it's not something I'm after at this
point I don't want to play for the
Lakers first of all let's just be honest
I'm a Clippers fan second of all I'm not
NBA material actually never was
um
but in this dream I was drafted into the
NBA
and I was still living at home but I
also had Shepard as a son
which was weird
and I was in my childhood bedroom and I
was packing up to go to La for my first
game
and I couldn't find my basketball shoes
and I was like I think I they're they're
the Nikes I was like yeah they wear that
they wear Nikes
um this is for some reason in my dream
it was still like the 80s where all
everybody wore the same shoe versus just
people wear whatever they want to and it
was like they're the purple and gold
Nikes and I don't have them and I'm not
gonna fit in when I show up I've got
these green Reebok
I'm gonna get kicked off the team
that's just an example like every dream
that I have that I've been recording in
2023 the ones that I've remembered have
been like I'm in this situation where
there's a piece that I don't have right
and I'm sure that's a relatively
constant these are common dreams but I
just think there's a lot of
that again that waking up in the deep
end and I think that's a huge part of
what keeps me going because I just like
look at all this stuff that we've
committed to and all the stuff that I
personally want to do and that we
together want to do
and that we want to do as a company and
I just kind of like it's constantly
there in front of me and I just have it
that's yet to be very not be motivating
for me like it's just always very
motivating and yeah it gets stressful at
times but
I'll every single thing that we're doing
for the most part
is so engaging and when I say the most
part I mean like all the stuff that you
see very engaging there's business stuff
that I have to do that I that I don't
enjoy
um but what we're doing with good
mythical morning right now I'm enjoying
it more than I ever have like I'm just
having such a good time shooting the
show and that hasn't always been the
case you know sometimes it's felt like
work right now it doesn't feel like work
I love doing this show especially when
Link's not here no I'm just kidding I
love
uh doing the show with link I actually
think that
um because we don't end up talking about
a lot of things we save certain
conversations for the show you're
hearing us talk about things for the
first time sometimes
um this show has been a lot about
maintaining
uh our friendship in a lot of ways I
mean how many friends do you have that
you sit down and talk to for
an hour and a half every single week
right like if you that's a good friend
and of course we talk a lot more than
that but like this show is basically hey
our friendship on display
I love doing this show
um
and of course I've said it a million
times what we're doing creatively on the
rent Link channel I'm super engaged with
so all this stuff is stuff that I really
really want to do but I'm still figuring
out what it is about me that commits to
these things I just throw myself in the
deep and I'm like well you gotta tread
water you got to swim to the shallow end
you got to do something and that's the
engine that has kept running this you
know the way I do things creatively for
a really long time
I'm in therapy
so I'm figuring out exactly what that's
I know that there's like Performance
Based family things and this my
personality and all these things trying
to prove something trying to figure out
what it is that I'm trying to prove but
for me uh it's just a combination of my
personality and then my job because if I
was in a job that I didn't enjoy I think
I would actually get pretty unmotivated
because I can get a little scattered but
because I can take all these different
interests and all these things that I'd
like to see coming to the world and
there's a way for us at mythical to make
those things happen together as a team
um
it keeps me going
I hope that answered your question
Chris on Twitter introspect CP how do
you think you would have dealt with your
deconstruction if Jesse wanted her and
your kids to remain active in the faith
and how do you think it would affect
your relationship with religion with
them and with them had they remained to
this day
this is a really good question
um
I'll say I could imagine it would have
been very very difficult right
um
I know
families where this has happened
where one person decides that they're
gonna peace out from Christianity or
whatever the Family's religion is
and they've got kids
and I've seen this end in divorce
uh I think that's pretty common
because it's so foundational uh to the
way that you go approach things the way
you talk about things and sort of the
way that you taught your kids
um
but
I actually think that
um
you know I never there was never a
moment where I tried to like talk Jesse
into something or try to convince her of
anything I was just sharing
things that were happening with me
doubts that I was having how my [__] my
faith was being reshaped
in my worldview is sort of being Unwound
and you know she responded with tears
and panic
it was not good it was not good every
and I would hold back the things that I
was thinking because her reactions would
be pretty extreme
um
and sort of I would just kind of slowly
meter these things out over time
but slowly she started having her own
for very different reasons than me
honestly her own deconstruction
that I'm sure was at least initiated or
influenced by mine but I think I think
her seeing me
begin to deconstruct but remain who I
was and remain committed to her and US
gave her this sense of safety and
freedom to begin her own
deconstruction
and
so let's just say that that had not
happened
would have been really really tough as
it relates to the kids you know
interestingly
uh my kids man they were asking really
really difficult questions before we
ever shared anything before we while we
were still going to church you know I
mean Shepard was a little bit too young
but Locke
from yeah I remember the first time
he came back from church when he was
like four
and they had been talking about the
Israelites and the conquest of the the
promised land and
he had a lot of questions
about the nature of God and the nature
of genocide
um that we didn't have great answers for
at the time right especially that a
four-year-old could understand
he was asking some really difficult
questions that I never asked as a kid
you know so I'm not sure how long he
would have stuck around to be honest
with you
so I don't think uh his you know his
perspective on faith or shepherd's
perspective on faith has actually been
uh particularly influenced by mine
they're very much their own people
but let's just say that Jesse had been
like it's very important for me to
remain a Christian and it's very
important for me for the kids to remain
in the church and the faith first of all
I wouldn't have thought that I would not
have tried to change that
because for me the stakes
are so much lower than they were as a
Christian right that's that's something
that's very difficult just to understand
when I that's it was very difficult for
me to understand when I was a Christian
because when you are a Christian
and type of Christian that I was
the stakes are so high it is life and
death it is good and evil it is Heaven
and Hell
it is eternity right and these decisions
are so weighty
and when you deconstruct
and you kind of your deconstruction
involves an embracing of uncertainty and
just being like hey I don't really know
what I think about a lot of this stuff
and I'm kind of uncertain
and
um
you become a lot less interested in
trying to persuade people and trying to
change people's minds and so I think
that my kids having faith my wife having
faith
might be something that was a little
annoying at times you know if they were
to say something I was like well have
you thought about this
but it wouldn't be catastrophic in the
way that it would be catastrophic from
their perspective as Christians right so
let me say that a different way
so if you are
um
an atheist
and your partner becomes a Christian
you may describe that as catastrophic
but it really it might just be
disappointing or annoying or
complicating but it's actually not
catastrophic because you don't believe
that they are in danger of some sort of
eternal
damnation from God in separation from
God and separation from you
but if you're a Christian and your
partner becomes an atheist and you stay
in your faith that is catastrophic
because they are
you know ensuring their own destruction
Eternal destruction and Damnation unless
the stakes are so high
um
but that's not really a reciprocal thing
so I think it would just be like Yep
this is who my family is and I just kind
of deal with it and I try not to be an
embarrassment to them and we try not to
talk about it too much whatever
I I hope that that's what it that's the
way that things would settle and I think
that now because I've kind of been
through my sort of angry anti-christian
phase and I'm now I'm kind of more in an
open place and I you know I know that
people who are still in the faith or in
another faith
are in many ways just as Justified
um
in their worldview as I am I try to be
less critical
you know if people want to talk about
things or get my opinion about a
particular thing or the validity of
something or what my perspective on it
is I'll tell them
But ultimately as I said in my
deconstruction update
I feel like where I'm at is almost
exclusively a combination of my
particular disposition and the
circumstances that I found myself in in
this life and I think that's how most
people operate
and so
um
I wouldn't be
too uh judgmental I guess is what I'm
saying I would just be like Yep this is
this is the situation I'll tell you what
I think if you ask me but I'm not going
to sit and try to make my kids become
apostates with me
let's have another voicemail
hey rep
any artist
in the world of all time who who would
you collab with on a song
like a low down dirty country song or
nice blues song or Bluegrass I just want
to hear what what you think man this is
Hunter in Michigan I just want to say I
love you and uh you're doing a great job
all right thanks
I love you too Hunter
low down dirty country song
you might think that the answer to this
question would be
somebody I greatly respect like Merle
Haggard right
but I actually think that's not the
right answer
because I think when you do a
collaboration with another musician
you don't want them to be
a lot better than you
ever heard those collaborations where
like you got two people singing
and the one that's like really good
really stands out next to the person
who's collaborating with them
I'm not going to call out any examples
but you probably have an idea of the
kind of thing that I'm talking about
so I wouldn't want to like ruin
a song by collaborating with Merle
Haggard because his voice
you like when you listen to uh now if
you're if you're like a real like music
critic and like understand music you
listen to James and the shame and you'll
be like okay well this would be better
if you had a great voice like if you
really know you know
but most people are probably like I mean
she sounds pretty good you know but if
you were to listen to my voice right
next to Merle Haggard's voice you would
be like oh this is a this is a different
thing this man is operating on a
different plane there's a just a natural
thing that's happening and effortless
quality to it
so I would not want to collaborate with
somebody like that
um I actually looked up
a a list of
the most popular yet worst singers
of all time
and I found that these lists varied by
quite a bit but there were two people
that were on all of these lists
Bob Dylan
and Britney Spears
okay so popular musicians
who actually cannot sing and listen
no Brittany hate around here
um I'm just saying this is what the
people think and if you think about it
uh you just think about a Britney song
you're like okay yeah there's a lot of
whispering happening you know
there's not as much singing happening as
you think there is just go listen
right and Bob Dylan cannot sing We
already knew that he already knows that
but that's kind of the thing about him
right
so I think I would use this as my
opportunity and I'm using it right now
um
Bob Brittany if you're listening I'm
thinking about a three-way
musical collab
three of us
Bob writes the lyrics
I write the music
Brittany does the dance routines
music video
that's the musical collab of my dreams
I think it'd be great nobody without
shine anybody else
you know we all bring our gifts
you got any opinions about that Jenna
uh
uh I would love
to see Brittany choreographs songs with
you and Bob Dylan I would love to see
that yes
free Brittany hello Brittany
okay
May Wilson
do you feel like the pandemic changed
your perspective on parenting I know as
a team going through it my family slash
parent situation changed a lot and I'm
curious how it was for your fam
um
as I was indicating a little earlier we
were talking about the apocalypse
is it just me or have we become a bit
numb
to just how
tenuous this whole civilization thing is
right like as of today I don't know I
don't know what it's like when you're
listening to this but as of today
um we're on the tail of this pandemic
um
you know we got Banks
that are failing
and you know people who know more than I
do about this are like ah there's
nothing to worry about
and that bank these banks failed for
particular reasons and I tend to agree
with or whatever but
um we're basically in World War Three I
mean let's just be honest right I mean
that we're giving a bunch of money to a
country that is fighting Russia and then
there's like other countries like around
that country that are like giving their
Jets to the country to fight Russia
and I'm not gonna I'm not gonna talk
about the uh you know
the right or the wrong of the in the the
war
uh but I think
oh and also by the way uh there's aliens
right it's like or they're or there's
something right there's something that
like people who uh are informed about
this stuff and have information access
to information about things that we
don't have access to information about
I'm not talking like conspiracy level
stuff I'm talking about senators who
have been briefed on things and come out
of meetings and say things like there
are things that the American people
deserve to know
what are you talking about and it's not
even surprising to us anymore
wait
we don't even call anybody right
it's just every single day
um
I I answer it in that way may because I
was thinking about this the other day as
we were talking Jesse and I were talking
about our kids
we worry about our kids that's what we
do as parents right you worry about uh
the decisions that they're going to make
and who they're going to be and how
involved should you be and
all this
but the thing I said to Jesse was I was
like we live in a crazy crazy world like
when I was their age like so when I was
Lock's age when I was 19
it was 97
1997 right
I mean
I don't I think people forget I think
people forget what it was like to be in
the 90s
this is so this is like pre-911.
so that like late 90s
pre-911
it was just like anything's possible
anything's possible like we live in this
great country we get we got everything
that we need oh you just you just you
just go to college and then you get a
job and you live the American dream it
just seemed really really simple
and then it you know reality
and first of all let me just say that
wasn't the case for everybody I'm
talking about me
upper middle class white boy from North
Carolina okay I'm just talking about my
situation
that wasn't the case for everybody
but that was my perspective at the time
now I'm I'm like there's so many things
going sideways that I don't even
understand what my kid's life will be
like when they're my age like what is
the what is the world going to be like
so I would say
yes the pandemic and then every other
thing that I've mentioned and all the
things that I haven't mentioned have
actually pretty substantially changed my
perspective on parenting because at this
point
the thing that Jesse and I talk about is
like
we just want to have a relationship with
our kids
like if we can have a good relationship
with our kids
that's we we've won at the game of life
right
like what are they gonna do now what are
they who are they gonna be and what are
they going to do for a living what are
they going to care about it's like
I mean I just hope that they're healthy
and that I have a relationship with them
not that not that we don't continue to
have conversations about what's the best
decision to make
in this area of your life and like you
know if you have if you have one advice
we're going to give it to you but
I try to hold on to that like
I mean we might just be like in a in a
apocalyptic landscape going around
dressed in animal skins
you know what I'm saying
that could be the reality
I just want a relationship
uh Rebecca Bryson for the love of God
what did Los Angeles that's my life
get you for Christmas last year you
absolutely left us hanging for over a
year
I did didn't I I did and I'm sorry about
that
um well I'm going to tell you right now
what she got me
just and I don't think I'm gonna show it
to you
but I'm going to tell you what she got
for me
but I'm not going to show it to you
right now maybe never
foreign
and that is because
Jesse uh was getting to know
um well she had a friend that she was
doing some work with
she was talking about how I just don't
know what to get him for Christmas I
want to and she actually meant to get
this for my birthday but timing worked
out so it ended up becoming a Christmas
present
she was like he really likes pen and ink
art
because we had gone and stayed at this
place
um
in Big Sur
for our 20th anniversary had a great
time up there
and you know we had planned on going to
Italy
pandemic happened
and so we kind of splurged a little bit
on a California vacation
stated a really nice place in Big Sur
and they had a
um
it's one of these places that they kind
of know that the people staying at this
place have money and so they have like a
shop on site that's got all this
ridiculously expensive stuff
um that we typically do not buy you know
um
but it's but we were like we're going to
look at this stuff so we like go into
this little gift shop that's got jewelry
that's just that tens of thousands of
dollars for these pieces these handmade
pieces and stuff
but then on display there's this giant
drawing
I mean like 12 feet wide
pen and ink
you know and I immediately I'm just so
drawn to it like this is this crazy
intricate world that like the closer you
get to it the more detail comes out in
this thing but it's this giant world
and then the woman sees me looking at it
she's like oh you you see you the
so-and-so has caught your eye
um well let me tell you about that and
she goes on to tell me that it's these
two artists in Brazil
the either one or both of them are
ambidextrous and draw
ambidextrous not ambidextrous
ambidextrous and draw with both hands at
the same time
in this particular picture which is
called something took them over a year
to make in that this was the original
and I was like well how much is it she
was like it's a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
and of course I'm like um
okay act like that I know sure of course
I did not did not purchase it
she said we have a print of this
in uh in one of our rooms
um
and I believe that uh
I believe that the the the the guests
of that room are I think I think that
they're out of there
and uh
as we're walking to the room to see the
print
we see
John Hamm
and his girlfriend
who he met in Big Sur
spoiler alert about Mad Men final season
takes either he gets he gets groovy in
the
in a Big Sur with this woman and they
became real life partners
anyway
we went into
uh the room that they had been staying
in which is where this print was
and we looked at the print she didn't
get me the print by the way because that
print uh all just the print was like
eighteen thousand dollars okay so again
I don't spend that kind of money on art
and but she's telling a friend about
this
and the friend is like I have a friend
who is actually really good at pen and
ink and he'll he does commission pieces
and she met with this guy
Ronnie Ray
Ronnie Ray Mendes
and she basically Jesse wrote like a
couple of pages about our life story
and he used this life story
to do a
like four by six feet
pin and ink drawing that was
representative of Our Lives
in it was incredible
it wasn't
12 feet wide and in Jon Hamm's hotel
room but it was incredible and it was
incredibly personal it ended up taking
him longer than he expected because he
hadn't done a piece this big before
uh maybe I'll show it at some point but
I feel like it's just so personal and
it's so much about us
um but that's what she got me for
Christmas and she said it was the best
she was like I'm gonna give you the best
gift that you've ever gotten and it was
very very much so the best gift I've
ever gotten and I'm sorry I forgot to
tell you about that until right now
let's do
um
couple more voicemails and I'm gonna do
a rapid fire to finish up
hey Rhett this is Maggie from Denton
Texas I was wondering are there any
habits or traits that you've picked up
from link over the years that you just
can't seem to shake
love you guys
it's a good question you know I was uh
I was talking to Shepard recently
recently as in the past year
and uh I was like Shepard's talking a
little different well actually
I'm picking up on the fact that
Shepard's talking a little different
just a slight sort of one of those
can't really put my finger on exactly
what it is that's different about the
way he's talking
something about the inflection
and then I met his new friend
and I was like oh okay
he's talking a little bit more like this
guy
which that's something that's very very
common right get into a friend group
there's just these little subtle things
about the way they communicate
and so when I read this question I
thought to myself well if there has to
be so many mannerisms and ways of
expressing myself that are very rooted
in my friendship with link
I don't know if you saw this Stevie sent
it to us
um I don't know I can't remember the
account but website somebody posted a
tick tock called Rhett and Link being in
sync for 10 minutes or something like
that
and it was exactly what it sounds like
it was like a montage of all these
moments that we had been perfectly in
sync with physically but what we're
saying and then sometimes just the
noises that we're making and we're
pretty different guys right you know we
there's a there's a contrast between the
two of us
that I think really works for our uh
what we do for a living in the
entertainment business you wouldn't want
two of me and you wouldn't want two of
him
um
but we work well together as a team
but I don't know what those things are
I'd have to have somebody Point those
things out and I think they'd be so
ingrained into who I am that you'd have
to go back to
I don't know I've known him since I was
in freaking first grade
so I I would be such a different person
for multiple reasons not just because of
the way my mannerisms or my expressions
or whatever have been influenced in the
way that his have been influenced by me
um
there would be a lot more than that but
I'm sure that those things would be um a
part of it but one thing I will say that
I definitely thought about in answering
this question is
as you might have noticed link has
always been a few steps ahead of me uh
in the fashion Department
in the past year or two he's begun to do
a little bit of a Sprint in the fashion
Department which uh
you know
when you are in a uh when you were in a
Duo an entertainment Duo of any kind and
you have to appear with each other
in multiple settings
not the least of which is your show that
you're together all the time on
um
somebody moving forward at the pace that
link is moving forward in his fashion
expression Zone
uh it has an influence on me because I'm
the guy that if I could wear the same
thing every single day like Dennis the
Menace that's what I would wear
right
um it would be like a comfortable
solid
collar shirt
that fits like this sleeves rolled up
some sort of like not skinny but not
loose
jeans probably like those Lululemon
pants that are just more comfortable you
know
the ones I wear when I'm flying
and then some like Dad tennis shoes
which by the way I bought the deadest
pair of tennis shoes I can't wait to
wear them on the show
you would not believe how big the
bottoms of these things are and I think
they're fashionable I think I'm not
really good at picking up on those
things anyway
what I'm getting at is that uh while my
style is not
um informed directly by link because I'm
not trying to do the same things that
link is doing
if you see me wearing like a new shirt
or a sweater or something that seems
interesting
it's because if I don't do that it will
get too imbalanced
that's the honest reason let's see so
link has a direct impact on my fashion
and there's things like
um
okay when the genes started getting
really skinny right like of course link
was going to be the one to get the
really skinny jeans earlier than me and
I'm just like man I'm six foot seven I'm
gonna look like a [__] idiot in these
jeans
you know I got other things I got to
think about I'm too tall for this
but eventually here I am with my skinny
jeans because I can't be the guy next to
the guy on the internet who's got the
fashionable skinny jeans on and I've got
like the dad jeans on
I'd be fine being the guy with a dad
genius on but I just got to keep the
balance intact
and then now of course it's like well
now the genes are getting big again and
there we gotta roll them up and they've
got to be bigger and
they don't look good by the way like the
skinny ones and the big ones neither of
them look good a good Gene is just like
a Levi's 501 I mean if you want to be
honest about it it's just a straight
Gene that's just covering your leg and
keeping you from getting caught in
Briars and stuff I mean that's the
purpose of a gene right
that's what I would have is I would have
a functional outfit
and the day that we stopped doing this
which is probably never by the way uh I
will just wear
basically like five shirts and five pair
of pants
that's what you'll see me in it'll be a
little bit boring
so yeah that's one of the ways that uh
that is a trait of link that I have
picked up uh is my fashion ability if I
have any
and one last uh voicemail before we get
into some rapid fire because I wanted to
get to as many questions as possible
a little birdie told me Rhett's
recording a solo episode
so I thought I'd ask a burning question
I've had for a while
Rhett what's your favorite kind of
cheese please let me know thank you
what's my favorite kind of cheese
whoa
that gets me excited when you ask me
these things
I've had so many good cheese
Jesus I've had so many good cheeses
but I do think I have a favorite
um
when we were in
Amsterdam
Jenna are you an Amsterdam no I mean I
was just not with you all oh gosh no
I've made a mess you were in Australia
with us that's where yes
well when we were in Amsterdam
um
we did the thing where you do like the
tour and you like go see the you know
flower fields and you see the windmills
and you see the wooden shoes that no one
actually wears
and a cheese shop is a part of this stop
I don't think it's actually in I think
they say hauda which is Gouda you know
we get we we say gouda but it's hauda or
something like that
in Dutch
it's an actual city right it's where
that cheese comes from
and at this cheese shop that was one of
the stops
they had
aged gouda cheese aged at different
levels
there was like some fresh or like a cut
like three months one year in three
years
and of course we got the cheese and
Christy was there she got the cheese as
well
we kept this cheese for months because I
was just eating a little bit of it at a
time
and specifically the three-year aged
gouda this is what happens when gouda
cheese ages
you've probably had some cheese before
that had it was like a kind of a smooth
cheese but as you bit into it there are
these little crystals these little
crunchy parts to it right
I don't understand what's happening but
that happens with some cheeses like it
happens with cheddar happens with Gouda
it happens with parmesan
some sort of chemical thing happens as
it ages so a good aged cheddar will have
this as well
where it just has this incredible creamy
sort of
uh intense
like creamy texture with these intense
like
Crystal
bites that are in there these pockets of
crystals and then the flavor is just
it's intensified and it's like gotten
smooth but intense somehow
so I would say it might it might sound
like kind of a
too a little too simple of a cheese
answer to say aged gouda but I just
don't think it gets better than a really
good aged Gouda
you should try it if you haven't had it
go get some three-year aged gouda from
somewhere
I'm sure you could get older older than
that but that was the oldest day out of
this shop
that's my favorite cheese
I haven't necessarily found a brand
brand here in the states that
was as good as that I had in Amsterdam
now for some rapid fire questions uh
from Twitter Vanessa what are some
things that sound like compliments but
are actually insults
this is easy
I used to watch your videos as a kid
Matt dippong have you done any sensory
deprivation floats since the GMM episode
several years ago I have in fact after
that episode we got contacted by someone
who ran a local float place
and uh before the pandemic I went a few
times
haven't been since I gotta go again
thank you for reminding me
Kaya
do you have a secret Instagram Twitter
etc for nefarious or other purposes nope
I don't
Josh Bell is there any part of being an
engineer that you miss nope
hardly a professional
what you rather do abstain from eating
beans for two months or get a shave and
a buzz cut
as much as I love beans I would go the
rest of my life
if I had to
you're not going to see this face
without a beard
anytime soon unless I mean maybe for a
lot of money for charity or something
but even then it's going to complicate
so me shaving will complicate so many
other people's lives
that it probably won't be worth any
amount
you know Jenna's like oh yeah I can only
imagine yep
the continuity conversations around here
anytime a haircut happens Godly like
link changing his damn glasses
oh man created an uproar so much
consternation around here you don't even
you don't even know how the system works
around here you have no idea they're
like but we have like five months worth
of merch drops planned based on his old
glasses and thumbnails and all anyway
me shaving would be a problem the least
of which being the way I looked
Gracie Archer Rhett should I get a puppy
yes of course you should Serenity
Pharaoh pal
do you ever wish you could be shorter
yes
6-2
Madison Lessner how many chuggers do you
say before choo choo
eight
Caitlin Kent have you thought about
getting any more tattoos yes Caitlyn I
have I talked about this a little bit on
Good Mythical More I would like to get
something on my left forearm
right now the best idea I have is a full
blue whale skeleton that covers the
entire
inside of the forearm
I may get a better idea but I would I
really like that idea trend
do you have any stuffed animals or
perhaps physical items that bring you
comfort no matter what
they could be from your childhood a
recent purchase something that just sits
on a shelf Etc I don't but I do find
that I like holding smooth rocks
so sometimes my wife will find me a
smooth Rock and bring her home and I'll
hold it
not any Rock in particular
just smooth rocks
Ash if you had to die by drowning in a
bowl of soup what kind of soup would you
request
my favorite soup as I've established is
French onion soup
and I do believe
that I couldn't drown in that just so
you I mean I think between the bread and
the cheese on top I think I could keep
my head above water
or head above soup
and then I would slowly drink my way out
of it so foiled
Alicia when did you realize that you had
your life together
not yet Alicia
I'll let you know
when I get there we got a team of people
still trying
that's right that's right we're working
on it
laughs
and that's it this has been fun 85
minutes or so of your time
um yes we have we keep a count we have a
timer
if we've never revealed that to you
before we have a timer
just to know how long when did we're
being uh I knew I could do it I knew I
could go an hour and a half by myself
uh I'm not done because I'm gonna give
you a wreck and this is cheese related
and it is uh
a technique you should try if you're a
cheese lover that I found on tick tock
or Instagram
you've probably seen it too but have you
tried it
have you tried
just taking some grated cheese I use
sharp cheddar that's what I had at the
house
um
heating up your pan I use a cast iron
pan
dropping it into a pile and letting it
melt into just a cheese tortilla
getting a big spatula
picking up that cheese tortilla and
making your breakfast burrito
out of a cheese tortilla
good I actually took a regular tortilla
and put my cheese tortilla inside it
like a freaking Taco Bell menu item or
something you know what I mean and then
I made my breakfast burrito and I did it
for the whole family
and the flavor first of all
when you heat up and you heat up cheese
and it hardens a little bit and chars a
little bit you don't want it to burn
it unlocks like a new flavor
so that you still put the cheese on the
eggs and the bacon and the sausage and
the onions that you put on the inside of
the burrito
but the cheese flavor of this little
cheese tortilla and my wife she doubted
me she saw me doing this and I and I was
taking the cheese tortilla and I was
putting on top of the regular tortilla
and she was like it's not going to roll
it's not going to bend you've created
she said you created a chip I said no no
no no this is not a chip this is a
cheese tortilla and it is pliable and
then she rolled it up and it was pliable
it will stay pliable because it stays
rubbery it's a little bit crispy but
still rubbery if you're low carb you can
do it straight up with the cheese or you
can just do an extra layer in your
burrito and you will thank me if you
like cheese you will thank me
all right that's it that's the solo
episode uh we'll be back with a normal
red and Link episode next week in the
meantime you can ask us questions give
us comments at our voice message thing
1-88 earpod one also join the
conversation on the internet with
hashtag ear biscuits so we can find what
you think about this thing that we're
doing
and we'll talk to you next week
guys this
'd be kind of for us but um
as a girl that grew up in panhandle
Florida I had
had my fill of country music as I know
it like I liked the oldies you know what
I mean but for the most part I
completely have just Fallen away from
country music but James of a shame has
really
it really brought me back like it's made
me fall back in love with country music
like I was when I was like that
six-year-old kid so but it actually I
relate to it now so thanks
keep doing what you're doing
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]